One, they fund 12 times as much, $12 billion a year,
compared to the government of nutrition science that shows candy is great for
weight loss for kids. And that soda is not linked to obesity,
which is just nonsense, right?
They co-op professional societies like the American heart association,
the Academy of nutrition, dietetics, and fund their organizations.
The nutrition organization gets 40% of their funding from the food industry and
in their annual conference.
You're not allowed to take pictures in the exhibit hall because they don't want
people to see all the things.
[Inaudible].
It's terrifying to me because we're threatening our future generation.
We're threatening our global economic competitiveness. Uh,
we're threatening our ability to actually have good national security because
70% of the recruits for the military are rejected because they're
unfit to fight. It's, uh,
a national security threat that the generals and admirals have written a report
saying unhealthy and unprepared. I mean, just from,
just from the war in Iraq and Afghanistan,
there were 70 plus percent more evacuations for obesity
rated related injuries than for war injuries. I think about that, that,
that actually almost doesn't sound, it doesn't sound possible.
And then I just talked to a woman who works at the top level in the department
of defense a couple of days ago, she said on,
on the military bases that are just loaded with fast food restaurants,
the combat troops are not combat ready
because they become so unfit. So.
That's S well,
how do you get from knowing that this stuff ain't right to having all these fast
food joints on the combat basis?
Well, let's just like they have fast food in schools.
They have McDonald's Monday and taco bell Tuesday,
and Wendy's Wednesday 80% of contracts of the schools have contracts with soda
companies. Uh, you know, these companies are very smart and deliberate.
So while there may not have been bad intentions to start,
there is a lot of bad behavior.
Now they have a massive way of controlling the narrative about food and
confusing consumers, confusing the scientists and confusing politicians. One,
they fund 12 times as much,
$12 billion a year compared to the government of nutrition science that shows
candy is great for weight loss for kids. And it's soda is not linked to obesity,
which is just nonsense, right?
They co-op professional societies like the American heart association,
the Academy of nutrition, dietetics, and fund their organizations.
The nutrition organization gets 40% of their funding from the food industry and
in their annual conference.
You're not allowed to take pictures in the exhibit hall because they don't want
people to see all the junk food that they're promoting. Right? Uh,
they fund the American heart association,
which allows them to say tricks are a heart healthy food. Cause it's low in fat.
I mean, it's, it's frightening.
And they create friend groups for companies spent half a billion dollars on
front groups to confuse consumers saying that, for example, uh,
the pesticides and high fructose corn syrup and trans fats and smoking are not
bad for you. Like the American on science and health,
they spent $30 million fighting GMO labeling in California when they won that
battle. Uh, they fund social groups like the, uh,
NAACP and Hispanic Federation. So they,
co-opt the very groups that have most effected by these conditions like diabetes
and obesity. So they will oppose things like soda taxes. They were the,
one of the biggest opposition groups to the big gulp, uh,
recommendations from Michael Bloomberg, which I think it was ill advised idea,
but still they were opposing it, right?
Because they were funded by these groups.
They fund nutritionists and dieticians to go on social media saying we shouldn't
have soda taxes or that sodas, okay. I mean, it's, it's just insidious.
And then they fund the political process. So just on one bill,
the GMO labeling bill,
which was euphemistically called the dark act of dying Americans,
the right to know,
they spent $192 million in one year on one bill.
They spent half a billion dollars on the farm bill,
which is governing most of our food programs like food stamps.
They fund feeding America, which is a hunger group, which is great,
a hunger advocacy group to make sure we deal with hunger in America.
On the board of that group are high-level executives from the food industry,
which is why they oppose restricting food stamps for soda or
other junk food. Right? So now government is paying $7 billion a year.
The single biggest line item for food stamps for soda,
for the poor that's 30 billion a year.
Sicker. Then back to the Medicare problems. You mentioned.
The true cost of food is not in the price we pay at the checkout counter.
So you buy a can of soda. Well, let's look at what happens to the corn, right?
I'm off the soda.
I just feel that I can tell you that I haven't had a regular soda in God knows
how long. So here's, here's the health clubs, clubs. Hi, here's how the, the,
the, the.
So the connectivity works in corn. So yeah,
government funds the subsidies that support corn production,
these monocrop that are heavy use of fertilizers, pesticides,
herbicides that corn production itself destroys.
The soil causes release of carbon into the atmosphere.
Soil carbon is a third of all the carbon in the atmosphere from the way we farm
and contributor to climate change. It, it actually destroys the ecosystem.
Pollinators and bees are killed. Who's paying for that, right?
It destroys the rivers, lakes and oceans. As I mentioned,
and creates dead zones because of the fertilizer runoff,
then the food that's produced is the raw materials for junk food and for soda.
Then we pay for that to be given at the tune of about
$75 billion a year to the poor in food stamp products.
75% of that is junk food. Seven, 10% is soda. So they eat that.
And then we pay for Medicare Medicaid on the backend when they have diabetes and
obesity related illnesses. And so we're,
we're not paying for the economic or the,
the impact on our environment and climate where we're paying for it literally
four times. And that price is not in the can of Coke.
It should be maybe a hundred dollars for a can of Coke when you include all
those costs.
Right? Okay. You gave me a lot there. First. I have to jump back for a second.
You're calling it denote.
I always thought it was Dan and American standard to know. Okay. Now. All right.
All right. That was sticking with me this whole time. So I'm glad we got it.
Got it. Got the important thing out of the way you say tomato. I say tomato.
Okay. So you did grow up in Spain now, now it's a European company,
so that's how they say it. Okay. Fair enough. Uh,
that actually is perfect segue to my next question,
which is how much of this is uniquely an American problem?
Oh my God. Yes.
We have basically created the worst diet in the world and are exporting it to
every country on the planet. And what's frightening to me is, you know,
I was in China in 1984. It was no obesity. It was no diabetes.
Now they have a hundred plus million diabetics in
China. It's, it's the number one country in the world with diabetics.
There is that.
That's probably just a numbers game though. Right?
Just cause the amount of [inaudible].
It used to be one in 50. Oh, okay. So now it's one in 10. Okay. So yeah,
it's one in 10. Yeah. India is number two. And in the middle East,
it's one in four. I have diabetes, uh, in the developing world,
80% of the diabetics and, uh,
and obesity related issues and chronic disease are in the developing world, 80%.
So, uh, in countries like Africa in India, in China,
junk food, fast food is aspirational.
If you want to take your date out in America for a good time,
you don't take her to McDonald's.
But that's what they do in the developing world. KFC is a premium brand.
McDonald's is a premium man. Domino's.
My brother-in-law was living in El Salvador doing some work,
some research work down there. And we went down there and basically, you know,
I saw a Wendy's and there was a lot of Wendy's I think it was Wednesday Wendy's
and a couple other chain things.
And those were the nights that's where everyone wanted to go.
Cause that was sort of thought of as the nice stuff. Yeah.
Which is a very backwards.
For you.
And these kinds of shows because this kind of conversation wouldn't happen on
traditional TV. I was watching good morning America of the day.
And I was in a green room about to go on a show and I don't want you to watch
TV.
And there was the whole segment where they gave free Wendy's breakfast burgers
or whatever the junk they give them to the entire audience.
And then they were talking about these great Wendy's breakfast things,
and they were eating, the hosts were eating them, right.
They had a big ad after.
Because you know, the host would never eat that stuff normally.
No they wouldn't.
But the media is co-opted who funds the media and advertising today,
big pharma and food, big food.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about lifestyles,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our lifestyle playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist,
they're both right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.